i'm laura ingram this is ingram angle
from washington tonight thanks for
joining us
west winging it that's the focus of
tonight's angle
all right for months now we've been
telling you that things have been coming
off the rails inside the biden white
house so you got cratering poll numbers
you got higher costs for everything
people are leaking on each other now and
at this point you got to think that
working for this administration
has to be the most painful resume pad
ever
guess what since 1938
the republican two-point lead on the
generic congressional ballot is the best
position for republicans at this point
in any midterm cycle in over 80 years my
estimate for the 2023 house makeup if
the election were held today which again
it isn't we still have five months five
months from tomorrow would be
republicans 236 seats to 241 seats
democrats 194 to 199 that is a stomping
or that would be a stomach yes
yes it would and yes of course it's
biden who's the drag
in 1962 the president's approval rating
jfks was 71
bill clinton in 1998 it was 63 percent
joe biden's is just 41
why is his approval rating so low
well i think this slide will give you
the answer this is the net approval
rating on the economy at this point in
the presidency
joe biden's minus 26 points that is the
lowest tied for lowest for any president
in the last 40 plus years
the faces at cnn tell the story
here i think is the big takeaway views
on your on the economy are closer to
look at this republican party 51 percent
democratic party 31
republicans lead on the issue that's
most important no wonder they have a
historic advantage on the generic
congressional ballot
frankly i was shocked that cnn even did
this report it was well done but they
obviously see the writing on the wall so
imagine if let's say back in early 2021
you were really excited to get a job
with this company you were thrilled then
when you were hired
but then when you finally got inside you
realize that the ceo had trouble with
the basic subject-verb direct object
thing
i'm also sending to congress a
comprehensive package
of that will enhance our underlying
effort to accommodate the russian
oligarchs and make sure we take their
take their their ill-begotten gains
we're going to accommodate them
we're going to seize their yachts their
luxury homes and other ill-begotten
gains
of putin's kleptocrats
kleptocracy and clip the guys who are
the kleptocracies
i don't know what was most disturbing
about that it might have been the laugh
at the end
now the most competent person at the
white house was jen saki and now with
her gone things have gone from bad to
worse as politico confirms and a new
piece out today
aides need to quell the finger pointing
that's been erupting internally and the
increasing concern over staff shake-ups
according to five white house officials
and democrats close to the
administration the president has
expressed exasperation that his poll
numbers have sunk below those of donald
trump whom biden routinely refers to in
private as the worst president in
history okay pot kettle black
we're living through the worst
presidency in modern times right now
and since of course they can't blame
their idiotic left-wing policies they
just blame their staff
the first lady and the president's
sister are seething
members of biden's inner circle
including first lady jill biden and
presidents the president's sister
valerie biden owens have complained that
west wing staff has managed biden with
kid gloves not putting him on the road
more or allowing him to flash more of
his genuine relatable albeit gaff-prone
self
well
if the first lady and val are intimating
that his staff is incompetent well
they're they're kind of right about that
but on this rare occasion his staff is
100 right
how many times can biden almost start
world war three with off-the-cuff
remarks before they realize maybe don't
do them i mean thank god he's only done
one sit-down interview during the past
six months
this week he's going to be cuddly with
cuddly liberal jimmy kimmel
because what's happening right now to
our country is apparently
good for what comedic relief
but the idea that biden is going to turn
things around for himself by doing town
halls across america or late night shows
or sit downs with real journalists
it's laughable
the guy could barely read the
teleprompter and now he's going to do
freestyle domestic and foreign policy
just wing it in the moment
i became aware of this problem
sometime in
after april and early april about how
intense it was but moments earlier in
his meeting with top manufacturers we
knew from the very beginning this would
be a very serious event we
could foresee that this was going to
create a tremendous shortage did the
ceos just tell you that they understood
it would have a very big impact
they did but i didn't
this is why obama didn't think he should
run kids
now the staff isn't keeping him off tv
because they want him to have low poll
numbers they're doing it because they
know he is a complete disaster
has everyone forgotten what biden was
like on the campaign trail back in 2019
we choose unity over division we choose
science over fiction we choose truth
over facts we have this notion that
somehow if you're poor you cannot do it
poor kids are just as bright and just as
tall as white kids i love this place i
love look what's not to like about
vermont in terms of the beauty of it
new hampshire
he spent oodles of time in new hampshire
and iowa and got trounced in both states
it's not like he can lean on his new
comms team either to deliver a powerful
message
in the eu is eight dollars and fifteen
cents per gallon and has increased by
one dollar and seventy four cents in
germany gas is eight dollars and eighty
eight cents per gallon has increased two
dollars and sixteen cents in canada gas
is six dollars and twenty three cents
per gallon it has increased 1.93
there's no question that important
interests are interwoven with saudi
arabia and the president views the
kingdom of saudi arabia as an important
partner on a host of initiatives that we
are working on how do you have a high
level or effective immigration
discussion with the region with
the presidents of mexico and two-thirds
of the northern triangle countries
boycotting this event i think we're able
to still you know we're able to still
have
an array of conversations and really
focus on our agenda
these briefings have gone from somewhat
tolerable to downright terrible
everyone knows it
now it's up in the air which is more
cringy biden speaking without notes or
his press secretary speaking with them
i'm going to call it a tie
now what dr biden obviously doesn't
understand is that there was only one
argument ever for joe biden in 2020
and it was that he was harmless and kind
of an affable figurehead who would allow
the country to go back to normal
it wouldn't be any more drama
well obviously that's out the window
most people would choose some of that
old trump drama hyped by the media of
course over today's different type of
drama caused by bad policy
pretty frustrated because the cost of
living has gone up so rapidly to have
gas prices almost in the seven dollar
range that's difficult well when is it
going to end you know what i mean like
it's just it's just like a lot to take
in but you got to you got to get it
that's the thing you you have to pay for
the gas so there's nothing we can do i'm
i am quite frustrated by these
rapidly increasing prices it comes into
play
every single day do i want to drive to
the beach now or am i just going to kind
of stay put
yeah they want you to stay put don't
they now no one and i mean no one
actually wants to see and hear more of
biden or for him to sit in a room and
make policy
the man's already presided over endless
catastrophes on gas prices his answer is
to urge saudi arabia to produce more and
let venezuela sell it to europe
american driller sorry you're out of
luck on ukraine biden was snookered
we've already blown about 53 billion
dollars there and now russia is taking
more territory in the end russia could
end up owning a lot of the weapons we
paid for
and soon i promise you zelinski will ask
for more money and biden and the
establishment republicans mitch
mcconnell will greenlight it it's a
total travesty on china despite a record
high trade deficit biden is is going to
make it easier for china to ship
unfairly traded solar panels through
third countries
and today he declared an emergency to
prevent the commerce department from
using anti-dumping tariffs to stop this
form of cheating it's a total gift to
the ccp and because this emergency is
supposed to last 24 months it's likely
going to kill off our own solar panel
industry as far as i can tell
biden's plan for us seems to be the
following keep the border wide open hurt
the suburbs and rural areas with high
energy costs ensure that america
produces nothing really essential
encourage a lot of people like that guy
in that clip to stay at home remember
federal workers aren't even showing up
and then at the end of all that hope
that china ships us all the goods we
need
sending biden on the road
letting biden be biden hey that's going
to be a gift to us at the angle lots of
fresh new material gaffs after the fact
cleanups by the staff
but it will be hideous for the democrats
and more embarrassing for a nation
already ashamed of the guy at the top
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else